un anuncio calificado como un paso
decisivo el jefe de la conferencia de
obispos franceses comunicó este lunes la
respuesta de la iglesia a las
revelaciones sobre las agresiones
sexuales contra menores cometidas a gran
escala en el seno de la institución
católica de francia las acciones
compensatorias acordadas comprenden
indemnizaciones monetarias para los
supervivientes financiadas con el
capital eclesiástico incluso con la
venta de patrimonio
acz y todos los obispos aceptaron y
decidieron identificar las propiedades
de sus diócesis que se pueden liquidar
también decidimos que si es necesario
nos endeudaremos para cumplir con
nuestras obligaciones
la decisión es fruto de la reunión anual
de obispos que este año tuvo lugar un
mes después de la publicación del
explosivo informe que reveló los 216 mil
casos de agresiones sexuales contra
menores por parte de miembros del clero
francés desde 1950 una cifra que
asciende a 330 mil si se tienen en
cuenta los delitos perpetrados por
civiles relacionados con la institución
delitos que fueron encubiertos de forma
sistémica por parte de la iglesia según
el mismo informe además de las
compensaciones económicas se establecerá
un organismo independiente que
reconocerá a las víctimas y gestionará
sus demandas y se creará un tribunal
eclesiástico para juzgar a los miembros
del clero involucrados en las agresiones
los obispos también hicieron un llamado
al vaticano solicitaron al papá
francisco que mande un representante
para examinar el trato de los
supervivientes queda por esclarecer la
suma de las compensaciones económicas
pero la conferencia prometió que los
primeros pagos se efectuarán en 2022